this is your first major film role first
role at all first role at oh yeah I've
never acted before
wait a minute so you've never acted
before and then you land the role of
tupac shakur right
that's unbelievable certainly is me yeah
unbelievable to be here now Conan yeah I
mean did you do you must have done some
acting before uh oh I had a play in six
great that was the only experience
before playing tupac shakur was that you
were in a sixth grade play
yeah well bleh was that um the Christmas
chorale something out and I my character
was bubblegum Bart it was some Christmas
play bubblegum Bart yeah I was coming in
and destroyed a town I was the bad guy
right why was your name bubblegum I was
going to wipe the town out with
bubblegum thank you
you okay I've done that your your resume
really is I played bubblegum Bart and
then tupac shakur what a leap right do
you remember any of your lines from that
play uh did you get was it did you get
to be funny well yeah uh actually kind
of like stole the show then um there was
like because I was like the bad guy yeah
they're like oh you know Bart we like
you you know you don't have to be bad
we like you barn all you do and I bet
you got the bug right there yeah when
you score I don't care what age you are
when you score in front of an audience
like that you have a bug it was like the
same reaction they all allowed I loved
you